let's start with you exactly what point
did the SNP become interested in the
plates of the pure fox you've done
nothing about it as a majority
government in the Holyrood you know that
there's a lovely picture of you in the
manifest store but there's nothing about
fox hunting and there when did you
suddenly decide to become their defender
well as with anything else in the House
of Commons we've said that we will look
at each piece of legislation on its
merits and we'll take a position on what
to do about it and it's not a position
you've reversed the long-standing SNP
policy which means a lot of sacrifice on
matters that only affected England well
that's not the case we well we reserve
the right to decide whether or not
things affect our constituents we were
elected to represent on this question is
two things that actually come together
one is that there is a Scottish interest
one of the ironies of this is that
actually the debate has thrown up the
fact that the Scottish legislation could
be improved and the First Minister said
that in fact there's going to be a
review of that take place so we're
looking to toughen up the Scottish
legislation perhaps to bring it in line
with the existing English legislation
and therefore we'd like the situation in
the rest of the UK to stay as it is in
the interim but the second point in this
is very important is that we said quite
clearly in our manifesto that we sought
not just to represent Scotland in the
House of Commons but to be part of a
progressive alliance in Britain and to
play our part in you know in looking for
progressive policies and we have been
inundated I've been inundated with
literally hundreds almost a thousand so
you've actually gone from not forcing
the matters which affect England and
England alone to voting the matters that
affect England in England or people
contact you on Twitter no no it's not a
matter to whatever seat over 1,000
emails and letters in this subject from
people in England asking the SNP to take
a stance as part of a British
Progressive Alliance and that's what
we've done and you know we the hunting
Lobby have run away from the debate and
from the vote but that's up to them
Peter boon I mean the the timing of this
it is remarkable men trust though you
defend the decision and the Prime
Minister not to go ahead with the vote
which was ultimately a free vote in the
House of Commons well it was a free vote
in the House of Commons what I preferred
it to go ahead probably would have done
it would have shown him property of the
SNP that mean it's just political
opportunism
I mean basically that they started when
they came to Parliament quite well now
they're laughingstock they've given up
the
principles for a quick win and you're
just gonna be laughed at now I know what
you're gonna do is you're gonna make
English votes for English laws much more
like actually of course that's what you
want no one's giving up any principle
we've said we will examine each proposal
as it comes always come and we will take
a decision in the case by case may you
tell you what Nicola Sturgeon no Angus
Robertson has said it's completely
iniquitous that English MPs can vote and
couldn't vote and devolved issues
Scotty Schmitt MPs could vote on matters
only affecting England you know as
recently as February the first minister
was saying that this was a policy that
the SNP dealt and in fact actually a key
example was foxhunting yeah well I mean
and Nicola Sturgeon said quite clearly
today that in fact she's changed her
mind on that on that question I think
it's refreshing that pollination
particularly when they received so much
communication from English members of
the public wanting them to take a stance
and folks something I think it's
important that we that we've been able
to do so so this is nothing to do with
English votes for English laws as the
First Minister itself alluded to earlier
I'm more than happy to talk about
English votes for English laws I mean
the proposals that the government
brought forward last week were
ham-fisted and shambolic and they've
decided now to put off the vote until
October that's a very good thing so we
can have some property debate I've
actually made you made that passing of
that policy even more likely now in fact
it seems likely that number 10 might
even choose to toughen oh yeah yeah I
think if they proceeded to try and
create two classes of mail here House of
Commons
then I think that would be a
constitutional outrage we already you
know that you cannot vote in Scotland
which your Scottish MSP suppose you
don't have the constituency will work
because they do it and what there's
always been two classes of MPs ever
since devolution and what we need to do
is answer the West Lothian question we
need to give English votes for English
laws which means that only English MPs
represent sorry MPs representing English
constituencies to vote on things that
only affect England and the animal
welfare statutory instrument which was
nothing to do with repealing the
foxhunting Act was a prime example where
they intervened on
something where they've got exactly the
same lure in Scotland well it it's
ruined your reputation
it's a fundament you will regret this
because people are now saying you can
never believe a word the SNP say well I
think the strange situation is it you
know very well Peter that the
Conservative Party does not represent
English public opinion on this and it's
fallen to the SNP the emails of
hypocrisy that you have had many a year
in Scotland with a majority to take
action and foxhunting you haven't done
so situation arises in the Parliament in
Westminster where there would be parity
between the situation north and south of
Gretna Green and you do decide that this
is the point at which you do a u-turn on
a key principle which is you don't vote
on stuff that doesn't avenge I don't
know what you mean we have
something as banned in Scotland the same
as it's behind in England there is a
concern about whether or not the law is
adequate and there's been some
representations made that and we are
looking now to strengthen and toughen up
look can I just deal with the English
votes for English laws because I don't
don't get me wrong in this I agree
completely that there should be more
devolution within England and that
people in England should be able to have
a say in things that just affect them
the answer to that the thing you need to
do is to devolve political power to the
regions and cities of England not to try
and create the shabby compromise in the
House of Commons where the parliaments
trying to be both an English Parliament
and a UK Parliament it won't work how do
you answer the point that the SNP have
have reiterated time time again mr.
Bourne that you have 56 of 59 MPs in
Scotland directly opposed to the
Scotland bill and they are seemingly
being ignored in all of them no the
difference is the Holy UK Parliament is
voting on devolving power into Scotland
but to Wales and normal and actually by
English votes to to England and that's
that is right that's what the UK
Parliament should do but when you get to
something that only affects a particular
country in this case England then it
should be English MPs doing and in
Scotland it's the Scottish Parliament
does it now you know Tommy says he
supports that principle well I'm very
pleased that the SNP are going to
support English votes for English law
but then on the Emma perhaps next week
they're changed in mind if they see
opportunism a
I'm afraid your principles have gone up
in smoke today and you're regretting
you'll be showing yourself next week our
principles are intact we've always said
we book consider each proposal on a
case-by-case basis basis and we'll vote
accordingly Scotland has decided last
September to stay in the United Kingdom
we're determined that Scotland will be
well represented and where we can we
will form gonna work where we can we
will form alliances with other partners
Joseph I ask you to resist it
the SNP arrive at the decision to do
what appears to some people to be a
u-turn on voting on matters that only
affect England I'm told there was quite
a vigorous debate last night a bit which
took place in private because as an SNP
MP you've signed a contract that I've
never heard of with any other political
party will you agree to simply tour the
public lightly the party line when in
public
keep holder sent out of the public eye
that's ridiculous I've signed a set of
standing orders we shall follow the
decision of the group and obey the width
the same as Peter would for well we had
a full discussion we discussed more than
frank discussions but it was a very very
thorough discussion with a lot of very
good points made and in fact some people
did change their mind Ernest during the
debate so some people because agreed
with the u-turn
no no the concerns but actually the
group arrived at a consensus position at
the end but after a full debate where
everyone was able to put their point of
view and what we've tried to do is to
square the fact that we want to be as
you know take take part in this stand up
as part of a Progressive Alliance in
Britain - what the concern and is
supposed to be a free vote by the way
but it's clear you're always gonna vote
on the whip I mean it is an
extraordinary if not always provide for
it you know it's about Tommy so I am
sure this is a topic we will be
returning to a number of times they'd
like to see as gentlemen thanks your
time this evening